glückauf mein name ist janine scharf ich
bin in veranstaltungsmanagerin hierauf
europolis der stadt aus eisen und ich
würde mal sagen herzlich willkommen beim
einen bagger
[Musik]
angela merkel ist für mich eine
durchsetzungsstarke persönlichkeit ich
habe das in den letzten jahren
beobachtet und zwar mit bewunderung wie
sie das nicht mit der faust auf den
tisch macht sondern immer mit bedacht
versucht ihre ziele zu erreichen
[Musik]
ich war ganz klassisch festival besucher
werden von einem freund mitgeschleppt
worden hat gesagt hier ist was los denn
dann stand ich vor dem bagger und habe
mich verliebt und seitdem bin ich nicht
wieder hier weg gegangen
[Musik]
geschlafen
bin ich natürlich noch nicht
[Musik]
meine nachbarn schlafen
heute steht auf jeden fall so richtig
früh an damit ich mal sagen wir gehen
raus ich habe ja auch europa ist alles
was ich brauche ich war schon
zwischendurch immer mal nach hause
und waschen wäsche atme dort mal durch
gucken ob alles nach am rechten platz
steht aber vorüber ist mein zweites
zuhause und dann sag mal sogar mein
erstes also ich schlafe ich nur aus spaß
hier es ist schon wichtig dass auf dem
platz immer jemand ist auch gucken kann
wenn irgendwas wäre von daher macht man
hat abends feierabend gemütlich mit den
kollegen und dann am nächsten morgen hat
man halt nicht die fahrstrecke und ist
einfach wieder hier und einfach ein
gutes gefühl
[Musik]
europa verlor
dass man morgens direkt angerufen wird
dass man gleich von null auf hundert ist
gehört halt hier auch für opel es dazu
und so ist es ja auch gedacht so zu
sagen dass man dem direkten draht hat
[Musik]
mein job ist auf jeden fall 23.7 würde
ich sagen und die eine stunde die da
nicht mit reinziehen die nämlich mehr
als frau sonst braucht man auch für
[Musik]
opel es liegt in sachsen anhalt und wir
sind auf einer halbinsel und diese
halbinsel war der frühere tagebau golfer
nord und hier wurde braunkohle
abgewandert
für opel ist ist die stadt aus eisen
also verreisen und polis griechisch
stadt für opel ist stadt aus eisen
also es war geplant die geräte zu
verschrotten der tagebau zu ende und sie
wurden einfach nicht verschrottet weil
studenten aus dem bauhaus hier
angekommen sind sich mit den bergleuten
verstanden haben und gemeinsam die idee
geschmiedet wurde wir müssen die geräte
erhalten also durch corona sind alle
unsere veranstaltung im letzten jahr
weggebrochen und das war einfach die
frage was macht man das können wir
machen wir brauchen einen namen und dann
haben wir uns einfach eine ganz einfach
eine idee besonders und gesagt camping
mitten im museum wo ist das schöne als
auch für opel ist und dann haben wir
gemacht also die politik muss
industriekultur als thema erkennen als
interessantes thema erkennen und
natürlich auch den wert der dahinter
steckt und welche schönen bilder hier
auch erzeugt werden und was wir für
werbung eigentlich auch für das land
machen
[Musik]
hallöchen na gut morgen
wie geht es euch du sagst vechta uns ja
super super hauptsache wir sehen auf
heiligem boden so zu sagen ihr seid
festivalgänger na ja wir wollten die hin
weil wir normalerweise aufs fest
übergehen und da das festival jetzt
einfach zweite mal ausfällt
trotzdem dabei im urlaub haben wir
trotzdem geplant
aber er findet alles statt aber er
findet statt
europas lebt von seinen festival sind
bekannt geworden weltweit durch die
festivals wir haben das melt -festival
wir haben das festival
[Musik]
die krone hat uns einen ganz schönen
strich durch die rechnung gemacht wir
haben versucht hilfen zu beantragen dass
bei manchen programm funktioniert bei
manchen nicht es war tatsächlich ein
kampf auf messers schneide
noch so ein jahr wie letztes jahr ohne
ganz ohne veranstaltung ist nicht so
richtig stemmbar
campingplatz war einfach so eine
spontane idee weil wir durch kodak eine
veranstaltung machen durften die aber
trotzdem einnahmen generieren wollten
also camping mit einem museum
habt ihr irgendwas was wir noch
verbessern müssen wenn wir das nächstes
jahr vielleicht wieder machen oder seid
ihr entspannt
die situation zu lassen und dann wenzel
und dazu
vielleicht noch mal ein
schönes geräusch
das einzige was nur sein könnte
vielleicht ein urknall birstein oder so
weil so ein bewegendes gab sich
mehrmals dabei es gibt ein
stromanschluss da vorne gibt sanitäre
anlagen also das ist super alles bei dem
wein ist natürlich toll dass die auch
ohne festival hierhergekommen sind das
macht mich besonders froh wenn man da
haben wir ein paar gäste von das freut
mich und wenn dann aber durch
mund-propaganda auch noch ein paar
familien dazu kommen ist das breit
gefächerte und bunt gemischt und das
freut mich
[Musik]
ja das ist der balkon 197 den habe ich
hier fahren
25 jahre lang
vom jetzt navi ist alles gut ja alles
gute für heute ich das heute mit uns
knapp 12 uhr mal gucken und auf dem bau
liste mit humor
[Musik]
monika hat auf jeden fall ein knochenjob
geleistet da habe ich großen respekt
davor richtig schwere schwere arbeit und
man muss gar nicht dass frauen thema an
sich so betonen sondern wenn man sich
durchsetzt und wenn man einen guten job
macht dann ist es doch ganz
selbstverständlich dass da auch eine
frau arbeitet
[Musik]
ich bin mit angela merkel aufgewachsen
sie hat für mich die politik geprägt was
in berlin passiert dann ich hab
politikwissenschaften studiert ich bin
einfach ein interessierter mensch und
habe immer genau verfolgt was da
passiert
[Musik]
monika weiß eigentlich stufen das hier
sind die wir uns immer hoch quälen
erinnern aber viel zu viel wer hätte ich
jetzt aber wird nicht länger immer
darüber aber drei etagen haben wir schon
auf jeden fall das sieht man auch den
den gesichtern an dass die schwer
gearbeitet haben und die geräte stehen
einfach für eine epoche ein
energiegewinnung die wir für die
nachwelt erhalten müssen den könnte ich
noch bedienen wie im schlaf obwohl man
gar nichts mehr sieht hier aber träume
oft noch vor das war der hauptschalter
ihr der
steuerspannung dass das pult ein und
ausschalten vorweg und na ja ein
bisschen was hat sich auch verändert an
einem arbeitsplatz und ein bisschen neue
technik haben wir eingebaut
die veranstaltung
ist ja auch schön dass das hier
weitergeht wenn mir damals jemand gesagt
hätte dass das ja so großes events und
sowas werden würde das
ist ja nicht nur das fleisch und meldet
das hätte ich nicht ablehnen haben ist
fertig nicht geklappt ich würde gerne
draußen noch was zeigen mal gucken
natürlich mit na ja wo sie monika soll
auch sehen dass sich das gelände weiter
entwickelt wir sind nicht stehen
geblieben wir erhalten die geschichte
nicht an sondern wir wollen die
geschichte weitererzählen und ich glaube
das ist auch das was monika wichtig ist
und was allen leuten die hier gearbeitet
haben wichtig ist dass wir das gelände
weiter entwickeln nicht nur bewahren
sondern auch neue ideen hier
voranbringen so dann müssen wir jetzt
mal ein bisserl den blick nach oben
treiben lassen damals eine solaranlage
installiert auf den dächern ach ja toll
und so wie er früher hier energie die
bot genau rausgeholt machen wir sofort
oben genau energieriesen wahnsinnig
wichtiges thema und jeder der herkommt
macht sich über das thema energie
gedanken also auf jeder erwartet auch
dass wir uns mit erneuerbaren energien
beschäftigen einfach damit man das
aussieht und genau das möchten wir auch
tun
[Musik]
das sind zu dünnschichtmodule das heißt
die sind relativ unempfindlich hofft man
zumindest
und das ziel ist es dass wir halt eine
bühne auf einem festival mit dieser
energie versorgen können also für so
einen gelände die uns wäre es natürlich
wahnsinnig toll wenn man uns auch als
spielort vielleicht für erneuerbare
energien sehen könnte für so etwas sind
wir auf jeden fall offen und da gibt es
auch schon ideen also wir können uns
solaranlagen auf dem see beispielsweise
vorstellen wir hatten auch schon mal
zeichnungen tatsächlich für ein windrad
im see wenn es dann noch mehr
unterstützung geben würde wäre es auf
jeden fall sehr sinnvoll es hat mich
gefreut dass du da warst wir sehen uns
wieder danke schön dass du mich ein buch
genommen hast
weil sie
ja ich hab gar anstatt zu trainieren
viel zu finden hat sie schon verlernt
gehabt
hilde ist auf jeden fall ein dufter typ
mit ihm beginnt eigentlich die
festivalsaison das heißt wenn er kommt
dann wissen wir es geht hier wieder los
und er gehört definitiv mit zur familie
für das sommerfest ist wichtig dass wir
relativ zügig fertig werden damit
geraten einräumen können das mag ein
bisschen sorgen um den boden der sich
aber noch mega gut aus der ist noch
müder gute laune und lily das schöne ist
für den kunden auch richtig wir bauen
die veranstaltung auf eine kleine
veranstaltung aber tatsächlich eine
veranstaltung das freut mich besonders
die jungs kenne ich auch schon reichen
die waren auch in den letzten jahren
immer bei uns und ich habe mich sehr
gefreut als ich sie anrufen dürfte und
den auftrag geben durfte dass die hier
im zelt bauen
das museum darf wieder geöffnet haben
wir durch den campingplatz öffnen die
ersten anfragen für veranstaltungen
trudeln ein also man blüht quasi gerade
wieder so ein bisschen auf dem gelände
endlich wieder
ein bisschen größer ist
haben sonst immer nur festivals gebaut
und so weiter ist alles weg gefallen
klar scheint ist ja geld das fehlt und
ja 60 kilo zugenommen ja weil er damit
bleibt der gleiche aber nichts zu tun
corona hat einen rattenschwanz ausgelöst
wenn man sich hätte gar nicht vorstellen
können also nicht nur wir leiden die
ganzen dienstleister leiten ich weiß
nicht welcher dienstleister vielleicht
im nächsten jahr so gar nicht mehr
existiert ein wenig jetzt neue aufgaben
herantragen kann also da wird noch
einiges auf uns zukommen von der neuen
regierung wünschen wir uns als
veranstaltungsbranche auf jeden fall
planungssicherheit wir müssen wissen
wann wir wie mithilfe menschen
veranstalten dürfen und das ist das
allerwichtigste was wir brauchen und das
langfristig
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir nicht
darüber sprechen ob es eine frau oder
ein mann ist ich würde mir sehr viel
mehr inhaltliche arbeit wünschen jetzt
nach kroner vor allen dingen müssen wir
an ganz vielen punkten arbeiten dass wir
wieder wirtschaftlich stärker werden das
ist ein bisserl besser geht s nicht
aufatmen können und ich glaube es ist
richtig wichtig das land neu
aufzustellen und
benni luk mehr porträts sehen wollt dann
schaut einfach in die mediathek